den gipfel des pilatus mit der bahn zu
bezwingen
das schien ende des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts den meisten menschen eine
verrückte idee zu sein
doch die pilatus bahn beweist dass
visionen wahr werden können
die steilste zahnradbahn die welt ist
seit 125 jahren in betrieb
das ist unglaublich das ist so stein ich
traue diesem zug ich habe keine angst es
ist aufregend
die schmalspurbahn schafft steigungen
von 48 und überwindet mehr als 1600
meter höhenunterschied in einer halben
stunde die steuerung der bahn ist
einfach und doch ist die arbeit des
triebwagenführer anstrengend auswertung
ist schon auf die konzentration zu
halten dass man fit ist einmal irgendwie
ein bild auf der schiene steht und so
weiter und hat dann auch den
höhenunterschied 56 und auch zu machen
die 1600 höhenmeter das geht dann schon
auch an die substanz
schon lange vor der pilatus bahn gab es
auf dem gipfel ein hotel das rund 3000
gäste im jahr besuchten das soll nicht
so bleiben
der ingenieur eduard locher hatte die
kühne idee eine bahn zu bauen und erfand
ein neues system eine zahnstange mit
zwei horizontal drehen den zahnrädern
eine scheibe darunter blockiert falls
die rede heraus springen wollen wenn es
steil nach oben geht
der bau war eine herausforderung
tonnen schweres material wurde nach oben
geschafft und tunnel wurden gebaut
doch in nur 4 100 arbeitstagen war es
geschafft die dampfbahn nahm im juni
1889 den betrieb auf und die gästezahl
auf den pilatus stieg um das zehnfache
erstens braucht man ziemlich viel kohle
zum feuer machen zu können und dann muss
die unterwegs auch immer wieder wasser
aufgefüllt werden
es gab dann mehrere haltestellen mit
wasser zapfsäulen damit man das wasser
wieder nach fühlen konnte und auch die
fahrzeit war eineinhalb stunden verkauft
und bearbeitung vier stundenkilometern
1937 wurde die bahn elektrifiziert
eine lohnende investition denn die
fahrzeit halbierte sich erstmals von
über 100.000 gäste auf dem berg
die triebwagen von damals bringen auch
heute noch die besucher auf den pilatus
und zurück zum vierwaldstättersee über
350.000 besucher sind es mittlerweile
pro jahr
die bahn fährt bis in den spätherbst die
witterung schlechteres hält er auch
geben dass die fahrleitung verreisen
dann kämpft man effektiv mit dem morgen
hoch wenn man zwischendurch keine stürme
erwischt und die strecke so steil ist
geht das maximum zwei meter überstehen
mit dem wort stehen seit 125 jahren
fährt die bahn mit den original
zahnrädern im depot wird täglich jeder
wagen kontrolliert der verschleiß ist
auch deshalb so gering weil eduard
locker sein system überdimensioniert
hatte in jeder hinsicht ein
vorausschauender mann
überliefert ist dass es knapp zwei
millionen gekostet hat der ganze baum
dass man auch im budget geblieben ist
was ja heutigen zeit nicht
selbstverständlich ist dass das ein
bauwerk in bücher bleibt und das hat man
auch eingehalten auch die termine
konnten eingehalten werden was doch sehr
erstaunlich ist aus heutiger sicht
und doch wurde das system locker nie
weitergeführt denn schon kurz nach
inbetriebnahme brach die zeit der
seilbahnen an die einfacher und billiger
zu realisieren waren die pilatus bahnen
dagegen zeugt bis heute von großer
ingenieurskunst